random challenge I don't sleep yeah this
was basically me this is me whenever I'm
awake whoo this is this is classical
casual okay I'll see if my point is here
if there's no move in like 10 seconds
Alexa saw the timer for nevermind let's
play five six generally I don't advise
to challenge me to such a long time
control but if you're a London player
you can you can get away with it okay
I'm gonna play against the London I
would have play the groom fouled but
it's hard to play green foul against the
London
if people are falling asleep that's okay
you have the right to okay London time
I'll try and make it exciting
I'll play knight c6 Queen b6 actually
depends on the move order that like
plays
that's why it has a few different moves
to play 90 - yeah 92 is is good move
I'll play I'll play this move the queen
bee six lines don't quite work generally
black would play Queen b6 with idea
after Queen B 3 C 4 Queen C - Bishop f5
but that idea doesn't work because their
work has mobility and then I would just
lose a bishop so I'm in the play well
one of my favorite lines to play against
the London the first this looks kind of
just passive like my bishop spots oops
don't know why I highlighted that but
there's very specific idea here for
black coming up it was not h5 I'm
violating many principles like I blocked
my bishop moving the same piece twice
moving a knight to the edge but it's all
with some intention I attack the bishop
so I gain time and in many cases the
Bishop d6 there's many cases where I'll
have Knight f4 ideas
I get vision d39 f4 there's also ideas
about 65
and generally the Knights will not go
back to up six there's a move here 95 to
attack my Knights well I would play g6
it's very common for black just to leave
the night here play g6 eventually
playoff six castle and e5 and just take
over the center oh you all know more
arrows I have to pace myself this could
be a long game
what's a good move to master to
middlegame it depends on the position
every position calls for different types
of moves the first principle don't plug
your pieces so I defend the knight f6
will come with tempo
playing London against me is like
playing groom fell against and vo is MPL
a d4 player maybe he mixes it up
but yeah it's interesting phenomenon
when you play it opening against a
player that the opponent usually plays
with other color generally I enjoy
playing London from both sides because I
try to be more prepared and than my
opponents so Bishop you too so
interesting decision time I could take
on g3 if I take on g3 and then I'd be
threatening to take on e5 light would
take on c6 and we train use each file I
get the bishop pair get the B file the
other option is this move I kind of like
this so
there's also some line where I sack my
queen
like just take a rook and then have no
that does make any sense
okay let's take a night and probably
rugby gates
there's before you'll also play c5
immediately let's play rook b8 hitting
the pawn
you think there is a certain game-mode
that results in faster improvement
I assume you're asking about like what
time control it depends I would say
longer time controls lead to higher
quality chess and also help build like
intuition that you should be used to
spending perhaps a a few minutes per
move when you're playing serious chess
but then there's also benefits to to
playing blitz because you can get in
quicker a number of game or larger
number of games and it's better for
practicing openings like if you play
like dozen blitz games in an hour can
get like a high volume of the same
opening so it kind of depends what
you're working on
clicking c5 as I have to bishops it
should benefit me to open the position
and I'm a very basic level the way to
open the position is to trade pawns to
go for a pawn breaks I played rugby aids
with some intentions that prevent Bishop
e5 there is Queenie forecheck but then
this move and Beach is undefended it's
kind of weird like we were both uncle
like white white wants to keep the the
rook here so probably doesn't want to
Castle kingside it also doesn't want to
Castle kingside
because I have potential to attack so
the key might just stay in the center
which means I probably want to open the
center my king would be Hawking on g7
the guy my castle put a rock on year
ovary five threatening this and double
attack
you should have played b4 yeah before it
would have been more restrictive
sometimes a problem with b4 is it makes
key four or five stronger because in the
event that we trade there's these pawns
are a bit delicates so yeah I'm not sure
I mean I think the way White's playing
is is alright but white has to be
careful here
ah so you're rating for slower time
control is higher than your rating for a
faster time time control I think that's
pretty normal
I'm not sure if like different ratings
for different time controls are more
inflated than others generally I would
say don't become too fixated on on
reading just try and focus on playing
good moves improving the overall quality
of your games
minimizing blunders how do you know if
people are not cheating yeah Lee chess
is pretty good about marking people if
they're found to be using engine
assistance so if someone is found to be
using engine assistance then they can't
challenge me or it'll like alert me so
yeah there's systems in place there's
bit of d7 my bishop defends a pawn and
now I'm attacking the Queen I'm also
attacking b2 if the Queen goes back I
still have this move Queen b6 so I think
I'm winning a pawn
henry lord watan welcome back when I see
that name I instantly think like do I
play G v g5 not called for my pawns are
happy just defending each other and yeah
my next move is going to be a pawn
capture unless lost my castles Queen
side then there might be some other
options but if lay Castle queenside okay
there's it's going to be fun
for question you have four questions
oh I have four questions I asked before
and after a move to avoid blunders ah
yeah
what's attacked what's defended what's
pinned what are the forks possible um
yeah those are I mean a big part about
chess is asking yourself the right
questions that are relevant to the
position so the general question to
avoid blunders as like what's the pawns
threats and does opponent have the have
a threat still after like the move you
want to play Queen takes B to rook b1
and takes and then black wins both mine
or white wins both my rooks but I have
Queen C 151 Bishop a4 Keeney to Bishop
b5 see for takes no that should be
really good for me
that's interesting try though wonder if
black to me that or white could have
made that work some way better
probably not some discussion about and
about chess books yeah I would say when
it comes to like any any chess resource
even any resource in any field sometimes
it depends on the person like what their
learning style is a lot about finding
the right resources as being like
self-aware and understanding what works
for you what doesn't work for you what
works for other people that have similar
learning styles to you also just
experimenting
but yeah videos are becoming not a big
alternative to books these days okay so
I'm a pawn
I've to bishops Queens are traded
Lentini seven rook b8 ideas
I'm not sure what arrows to draw okay
this is one arrow mmm why can still
legally castle he's so funny
casting queenside but not a castle fork
let's just move the bishop back bishop
here too not sure if there is a big
difference between you seven and d6 I
mean I preserve Bishop a3 but I also get
perhaps make the threat of Bishop f6 and
yeah the rooks just chillin the only way
to try and attack it is to get the King
to c1 but then there's always Bishop 83
wow the castle so I could also just take
a pond but this I mean this looks so
attractive mission a3 I'm oh I have a
free Bishop that's okay yeah that's good
advice chess is not a one-sided game my
good players look at they so look at
every position from both perspectives
yeah like I could have taken the free
bishop but there's no stopping either
rook takes Bishop or Brook takes Knight
next move
there's no way to attack the bishop on
III capital Greco welcome back if you're
just joining I've been streaming for for
three hours
streaming for a while had some
interesting games had one loss earlier
against Macoutes played a good game but
since then I've been redeeming myself
trying to build up confidence okay oh I
have the choice which piece to take I
mean taking the Knights I think leads to
a meaning kind of net yeah let's just
take the knight there's no force mate
feels kind of close and this can be pre
moved bishop a force stronger than rook
takes B - Oh like there's a fort here
ooh interesting yeah I could have just
that like soccer but at some point I
would just take a piece why are you not
supposed to castle in the middle game
sometimes you you could I mean it's a
good way to bring a rook to the center
of the board it always depends on the
position a very common mistake
I'll see among students is Bill castle
after Queen train and it's generally a
mistake because if Queens are traded
your King will be safe in the center and
usually preferable in the center if an
end game is approaching so if we pretend
this like the sort of position I wasn't
just going after the king I was playing
positionally I probably prefer Keaney 7
over castling the King's just more
useful and
and helping out later on yeah Sonia Lane
knows what's up and game you want King
in center yeah sometimes people forget
like in the opening you protect your
king and then game you use your King as
a weapon
sometimes it's close to meeting I can
win Connect four and pawn storm by then
I lose a pawn maybe like maybe g5 is
we're getting closer to g5 actually
making sense but not quite
I'll start with this move the King has
to move here or here came out for not
sure why King f4 would be chosen over
King f3 so yeah the position is
completely winning him but I'll try and
be stylish and the way it's finished
there's there's three legal oh there's
four legal moves king d3 I'd there's a
b5
if someone was asking who's this best I
am in terms of like what are the what
are the determining factors of being the
best in terms of playing string Collins
demon has to be up there
Hans demon has like a GM Norma - oh I
didn't even see John's comments and John
also commenting Hans Neiman saying Han
sniffing is up there Wow I swear I
didn't see that comment before before
saying that I'm so needed don't know
what that means but thanks for subbing
pretty sure oper and Hans are different
people okay um so I'm gonna play each
five just so my pawns are smiling also V
for victory
the idea with H five is to try and limit
White's escape because if G for the idea
would be to run the King so I'll I'll
meet G for which I could be G for by
taking just open each file it's really
just restricting G for I just want to
suffocate the king the Kings already
restricted by its own pieces the bishop
is pinned if the bishop moves anywhere I
I'm eight in one so I also yeah I
control the last getaway square for them
from the King the bicycle wants blood
okay let's see what I can do
I'm trying to conceive a scenario where
g5 is meat I think it would require
playing f6 z 5e for king f4 r g5 meats
so I'm I'm four moves away mmm
John John is quicker than Sonya my pot
always delivering the answers where does
a g5 mean come from
is it a meme or is it just an emote or
are all emotes memes or all memes emotes
I forget who was it it was either love
HS or Henry Lord Bhutan and one of these
these people
okay so let's take yeah each file open I
could I could push I'm now I'm just
trying to calculate mate I could take on
f2 there's all these different types of
mates like there's the possibility of g5
mates there's a line I was looking at
this line where f4 is played and then
like I try and aunt the slot with chat
mates
there's also the idea of castling with
checkmates there's so many different
like challenges I could challenge myself
to this point I'm just looking for like
force mates problem with e5 at weaken
the g5 and King g3 I kind of run out of
fuel
a5 a5 also interesting I'm gonna just
try and play like best moves
there's actually really beautiful okay
let's play a five first try reading this
and then this and pawns are gonna be
rolling King g5 can watch King g5e play
I think my opponents realizing some doom
if it hasn't been realized already face
chess face just with with deep
philosophy all emotes can be memes but
not all memes can be emotes mmm I think
I understand that also hello two-faced
chess with a face emotes
but is it the face meme the meme is in
the the emotes of the beholder right
I'm trying to still conceive of on
Toussaint means it's like if I get if
the King goes f3 I play g5g for King g3
there's a d6 it would force F 4 and then
I have on pass on the promised king
takes f3 it's on me also King f2 I could
also try and win Connect four there's so
many means I know you want it yeah I'll
try and deliver we'll see I mean my
opponent might just flag opponents so
perplexed maybe fell asleep
despite the username henry lord what
time i didn't even play g5 yet but
thanks for the bits now e5 e 5 s
possible if I try and do connect 4 I
just lose pawns you just went up on here
so if I play g5 for the Kings just gonna
enter my crib I play this move when the
King runs away
yeah let's just take up on there will be
opportunities to come I didn't want to
like fall into a wormhole calculating
like all these different possible check
lines the idea for now is just like win
the bishop I guess chase away the room I
was about to ask what does that mean
I guess that's uh this time control so
many fifteen okay so do I go for I
should probably take the bishop so now
I'm at least I'm controlling controlling
squares from behind g5 will probably be
like a sacrifice to drive the King up I
want to drive the team to f6 and then
castle with meats that would be so sweet
you also he five possibilities
how do you know when to do calculation
and when to just plan intuition
generally if there is like forcing moves
I'll try and calculate work h1 is
actually kind of annoying
rook h1 very annoying
what to do I could just take it the
problem is like I'm not gonna be able to
castle with meat almost like maybe play
Bishop h4h were reasonable oh you have
all the points I got rid of it because I
wanted to see how people would react I
guess this is a reaction yeah I was just
curious like if people would know this
I guess people know this I'm sorry I
I'll do a straw poll straw poll
oh gee 3 G's 3
it's kind of annoying
that's actually almost pinning Lin hmm
my rook has to save itself
I'm thinking bishops of b5 or do I play
g5 first ie five first g5 checking there
there so e5 here here I lose a thing I
do this King moves up not really
achieving much there
[Music]
it's kind of sad
I play g5 maybe I'll just play G v g5 it
happened it's not neat but ideas to play
g4 soon maybe win connect for hmm yeah
pawn still smiling
do i sack the spawn
now I don't want this game to like take
so long but I do want to calculate their
their their if I play this move oh
there's a nice kind of idea I'll play
this move
I appointed law on time
well I was gonna do a strawpoll should
always retreats I bring back later okay
there's your poll opponent doesn't let
me have fun I wanted to have fun
oh maybe you'll still have some fun yeah
let's have some fun cast bones
okay pushing stuff
push the more stuff
mmm Chuck
now pawns are being pushed get ready for
it get ready for it oh it's so much fun
King up six do it do it do it no oh I
wasn't a castle go back from the castle
with needs whether white likes it or not
Chuck
upon't wants to take back no take that
if you live with your decisions
also what are the results of this poll
wow it's so equal it's so equal no is
winning though maybe I won't bring back
highlighted comments Oh opponent moves
check check okay there we go
do it do it do it
no upon's King so slippery I do this
check oh I have master plan master plan
activated King a horse yes castling I'll
move fifty three the castle mates is
back I took work took a lot of work not
sure if it's worth it
do I put that on YouTube that was such a
long game maybe I'll put that on YouTube
it's worth the finish people on YouTube
if you made it till the end tell me your
favorite thing about chess